est-ce que vous seriez dans un club
libertin avec Bernard Bernard Montiel et
Laurence et une belle histoire d'amour
c'est
de l'amour on peut pas est-ce que
Bernard Montiel est toujours votre style
toujours
une histoire d'amour
[Musique]
il est magnifique dans sa petite veste
en tweed c'est très gênant
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que Laurent est-ce que Laurent
s'il te plaît
je trouve on en a déjà parlé alors je
suis très honnête effectivement très
très attractive elle a beaucoup de
je trouve qu'elle a d'abord aller
brillante c'était très intéressant les
conversations avec elles sont toujours
très brillante et j'apprends beaucoup de
choses avec elle et elle est très très
attirante ou alors
à tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
une autre s'il pleut des salaires que
vous venez faire une danse un petit peu
moi je veux bien le faire sauf que je
respecte énormément
les femmes
[Applaudissements]
musique année 80
merci de faire quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
viens de partir du boulot pour
ado
[Applaudissements]
elle me demande je le fais
les républicains
Bernard Montiel
réponse pour la vie
[Rires]
il
a déjà tout fait
parce qu'elle me fait la gueule parce
que vraiment parce que c'est ma faute
très beau très très beau
très beau Bernard vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
[Rires]
en tout cas ça me fait très plaisir
qu'il y a un couple qui serait vraiment
le premier couple TPMP
[Rires]